[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think when you take a look
at these two images do you see any
connection maybe maybe not
we will talk about it later now look at
this picture my dad keeps watching a lot
of movies of this man and he has his own
version of a very famous dialogue from
one of these movies there are two kinds
of people in the world the ones who
create problems and the ones who solve
them I want to be in the latter category
now let me tell you what I really want
to do besides showing simple
correlational pictures I want to solve a
problem a very big problem a five
trillion piece problem that's plaguing
us today the problem of what we throw
into our oceans did you know by 2050 we
will have the same or maybe more plastic
in the ocean and fish or if we were to
take all the plastic on the ocean
surface and pile it up do you know how
far it distance it would cover take a
guess it will be enough to start two
liter bottles from here to the moon and
back twice that's one long walk to put
into perspective the ocean pollution as
you can imagine is a very very big
problem while these statistics are huge
and mind-boggling what really moved me
was the impact that this race has on
life I learned something about whales
recently on July 2013
this young will ended up on the shores
of
northern Netherlands the people who are
very surprised to find an unusually
bloated stomach when they open it up
they found among other things - horse
pipes 9 meter rope and 37 pounds of
plastic its cause of death intestinal
blockage what emotions run within you
when you see this health a seal
entangled within this net anger pain or
perhaps even shame there are many more
horrifying pictures I have seen which I
found extremely disturbing every time I
see people eating fish I feel that we
are not just feeding plastic to fish we
are feeling it to ourselves as well the
plastic we dispose which ends up in the
ocean gets consumed by small organisms
which are later eaten by bigger fish
which just might be the fish that ends
up on our plate talk about the vicious
karmic cycle
all this while we're trying to find
water and life on other planets and I
think and smile we cannot do just this
life in water on our planet what am i
trying to achieve by searching it
outside of Earth with so much happening
around us got a big depressing and
overwhelming for me that I felt I had to
do something about it hence I came up
with an idea of invention that will help
make the oceans a cleaner place an ocean
cleaner called eros now getting back to
the two pictures we saw in the beginning
garbage plus the sink equals to eros so
what it was all about everything
indulgence ship it sucks waves on the
surface of the ocean and cleans it
it all started last year when I saw some
documentaries on what pollution and how
it is plaguing us I also happen to see
burn flats TED talk and the same problem
and how he wanted to tackle it then one
day as I came home from playing football
my mom asked me to wash my hands and as
I went to the sink to get the dirt off I
saw how the water flowed into the
sinkhole and an idea came into my mind
and I smiled as I saw the swirl of water
we're pulling down the drain I figured I
could use the same concept to suck in
waste from the surface of the water and
store it in the chamber so I rushed the
bathtub filled it with water my toys
opened a nozzle I was delighted to see a
whirlpool being created which started to
suck in the water and the toilets in the
tub and I immediately knew what I had to
do and so I went to my room
rough model a circle of ship with sauces
attached a very futuristic design much
like the USS Enterprise from Star Trek
we all of the series right so I zoom
around the house scrambled and collected
the following and flickable tube straws
connection pipes the scissors some
cardboard to make the sauces and voila
every swarm one was born this was just
the first draft the propellers weren't
automated and it only lasted seven
seconds in water before coming apart but
there it was my iris my vision of
changing the oceans I then got a little
more serious it's an exhausting research
and realized that the circular shape was
not very efficient so I redesigned to be
more stretched with girls I worked with
the 3d designer to make
the new design and model of Eris another
interesting fact I came across during my
research was that large ships like the
one you see in the picture are actually
one of the biggest pollutants on earth
there is high sell for fuel which
creates a lot of air pollution I wanted
to make sure air whistling become part
of that problem so I looked at noble
energy like solar and wind and cleaner
ones like hydrogen and orangey I
investigated inducing lighting materials
like graphene which is as durable as
steel and making it autonomous like
Tesla I eventually want to see multiple
elvis's man in the ocean cleaning and
scavenging the waste so what do I want
I wish to do as as doing my research
going through variety of resources and
after guzzling down innumerable cups of
hot chocolate hey I'm still a kid no
coffee for me I realized part of the
problem was that we actually don't know
a lot about the waste that pollutes our
oceans and so I started zeroing down on
the following things I really wanted was
to do the first to clean the country is
floating in the ocean second to analyze
the data from the waste which we collect
and the third stop that source which is
getting disposed by the ships so here's
how it works
the ship is essentially a large boat
waste compartments and salsa surrounding
it the working of the waste collection
is based on some basic physics concepts
like sauces rooted need to capture waste
a multi-stage cleaning which is a size
based separation and a compactor to come
back to trash the saucers float on the
surface gravity to create a whirlpool to
pull the waste towards its center these
saucers will have central outlet which
will solve with waste and
connected through tube to his chambers
in the ship
imagine a gigantic vacuum cleaner with
many cleaning tubes attached to many
dust bags once a waste and it's a tube
will have waste ages which one then
segregated first we have an infrared
sensor which alerts Elvis family in life
the waste then goes to waste chambers
for processing the first chamber is the
oil chamber which collects waste oil the
second third fourth and fifth chambers
of a large medium small and microwave
suspected li1 Swit and us those chambers
we analyze segregate and compact it and
pump the filtered water back into the
oceans beyond nervous I see myself
tackling of erosion problems like the
waste lies at the bottom of the sea and
the waste which lies on beaches I would
like to do more research on how I can
help
effectively dispose of the waste may be
process it on the ship itself or
creating different storage stations at
the oceans for holding the waste
collector ships can bring the waste
there and transport ships can pick them
back land someone asked me how confident
I was about the success of Everest as
Chris Anderson one flip put it this idea
exists and will always mean a part of me
and nobody can take that away this
before I end I wants to be a new
beginning of hope that one day I will
see my creation in action going there
cleaning the oceans and restoring the
natural habitat of our marine world
thank you
[Applause]